part of his qualification for the grand
master title but it's a difficult
tournament and uh lawrence i think this
is his first tournament in two years uh
over two years
at least so yeah but he did the best but
he did have the best victory in his life
recently he beat um his rival online um
greg shahadi uh which i think made him
very happy so they have some rivalry
going on there certainly yeah
international master lauren strength
fighting to become a grand master and
these two super grand masters have
started game two what opening are we
seeing it's early days but it's the
nimzo indian defense and uh this one
it's
could maybe transpose to some variations
of the queen's gambit declined if magnus
now chooses to push the black d-pawn
forward two squares
but uh either way this is a very decent
opening choice um very rich lots of
choices for i think that i think david
this this opening the nimso has been
scoring the best for black uh so far
throughout the tour so it's uh it's a
good choice
yeah which is which is massive you know
if you're scoring over 50 percent um you
know facing the serve we say really with
the black pieces because uh white has
the serve then it is it shows it's a
very good opening 14 games played before
this yeah and uh 60 over 60 score black
it's such a good opening that these days
most players with the white pieces they
try and avoid it uh even if they start
with one d4 they try to
maybe reserve the development of bla of
the white knight now on this left half
of the board of the white knight on the
c3 square normally you keep that as home
uh these days for a few moves longer
just to avoid the nimzo it's such a it's
got such a good reputation these days
and meanwhile up until this last move i
actually had this position recently
myself
in my match against nils grandelias but
now we might be heading towards
some of the main lines we might see a
trade of a set of pawns in the center
magnus now just choosing black has so
many options black's knight can come out
now black can push
a variety of different pawns black and
trade off for center pawns in the center
white's plan is much more simple okay
maximum tension now in the middle of the
board with pawns white is just going to
castle the king most likely
that is the main move and also a
friendly first time magnus place this
opening in the tour oh really this
season yeah i have zero games in nimzo
indian for magnus carlsen okay um okay
uh magnus though the reason that
surprises me kai is because it has been
his main opening for the last i mean i
think pretty much since he was a child
as black so that shows on the tour he's
been experimenting so much trying to uh
kind of show off these new ideas and
lots of different openings that he's now
finally against his main rival ding he's
come back to his old favorite oh
it's quite interesting i was just
thinking about what lauren said there
about it's very important uh the world
championships who who is qualifying from
the candidates which is not that far off
now um to decide if magnus plays and i'm
just thinking which names will magnus
play against and which won't he play
against and he's already said if farouza
qualifies it he'll play for the world
championships then but who else maybe i
mean i was thinking on top of my head
maybe ding
and maybe hikaru maybe they're the three
players but will tempt him to uh go for
the world championships again but
obviously it's it's a massive thing you
know i think most of us would love to
see him play in the world championships
and i kind of hope he changes his mind
really about that but you know i can't
understand why he might not as well yeah
i mean 14 high quality games between
these two to decide the world title that
would be amazing to watch
um meanwhile we did see ding kind of
just put his hand over his eyes a few
moments ago that's because he's just
trying to remember what to do here he's
definitely studied this position before
and the white king finally goes to
castle so temporarily white is one point
up but if you look at the white pawn on
the c5 square in the black half that
pawn is about to drop any moment
so uh we will see a position with level
material but black will have an isolated
pawn in the middle of the board
curiously i just check in the database i
can see that magnus hasn't actually had
any games in this particular line with
the black pieces but guess what he's
faced it with the white pieces um it was
in 2017 against wesley so it was a game
he lost
okay so magnus lost with white now he's
playing it with black
you see that a lot from the top ground
masters in the world they learn from
their own games i think that's a lesson
for everyone at home if you lose against
an opening or if you don't feel
comfortable on one side of an opening
often it means you should be playing the
other the other side you should for
example if you don't like the position
with white play it with the black pieces
and uh do you remember all all of your
over-the-board losses
no
for me no definitely not no i mean i
i've lived too long to remember all
those ones there's hundreds of them so
it'd be a really long list i i do i do
remember some of the more painful ones
though i think some games you know
they're like scars they they stick with
you for life and you you know won't
forget them
and maybe maybe you remember more bad
losses than wins i don't know uh
not sure what about you guys david i
mean do you you know i think that's the
thing every top player has countless
defeats behind them right um it's just
about learning from every defeat
i remember i think maybe not necessarily
the games like from start to finish but
i remember a lot of the defeats i bear
grudges as well if i've lost to someone
i want my revenge even if it's 10 15
years later
um
your anchor how about yourself
uh no not really um i i used to but then
as i got older and older then i stopped
remembering my losses
and sometimes i even forget my victories
as well and sometimes i even forget my
important novelties like you're
forgetting a lot of things here i know
i mean one of the worst novelties i've
ever i mean i was it was actually from
my character book and i was actually
commentating with you simon and we were
looking at young christoph's game young
christopher dudas that is and we look at
his game and i'm looking at this
caracane position and i'm thinking it
looks very familiar but it looks very
you were like was very dangerous and i
was like yeah it looks very dangerous
for black but it looks very familiar and
then i was like yeah yeah very dangerous
very dangerous
and then i went back and it was
bothering me so much i went back to my
room
after the game had finished
and i went and checked my notes and i
was like oh my goodness me it's my
novelty this is like the whole basis of
my book how could i not recognize this
and uh so annoying i mean i think as you
get older this happens much more
regularly because
i i've done this so many times you know
created created some courses i spent
loads of time finding some great ideas
that i'm playing and i'm like hang on a
minute i know this position but i can't
remember where's my mind gone you know
it's like i did so having having a good
memory is such a important thing really
and that's that's uh something for the
youngsters more than the
the oldies like me now i think i think
the thing is though i mean we don't
invest too much time in improving our
memory we can play you know like for
instance myself you know i complain a
lot about my memory but am i putting in
the hard work to actually do something
about it
no
are you
i'm no i'm probably doing the opposite
generally so
destroying those brain cells rather than
building them um i mean playing chess
and chess it is good for the mind
there's no doubt about that i mean i
know there's been various chats about
this but i find in general it's just
very you know calculating doing puzzles
it can only help the mind develop so
it's it's a really you know good thing
to have chest if you want to improve
your mind in a competitive way um but
yeah i mean david do you do lots of
memory exercises you know like you know
get pawns out and like oh yes you know
while you're going through your opening
variations no i should do more to be
honest that image in my mind though
little sweat bands couple of pawns you
know
yeah i mean i yeah i play through my
opening notes
semi-regularly my annotations of my
previous games but yeah not everything
uh sinks in anymore at least compared to
the past do you think magnus's memory is
something he's born with first and
foremost it seems to be doesn't it i
mean he seems to have some i mean genius
is an overused word but he seems to have
some super power with his memory and he
always has done um it's been proven time
and time again we've all got stories of
him recalling things which no one else
should be able to recall and he can so
yes he's got a superpower there i think
very yeah something special i mean just
last week uh we were celebrating the
17th of may here in norway and then a
song came on and he said david do you
know when i heard this first and
apparently it was in my car in wales in
2014.
how did he remember that incredible and
what was what was the song um it was
called kaley by the marillions i think
okay well that's pretty good memory as
well there you go that's only because he
told me last week
it's interesting this story because you
know other world champions had similar
similar things as mikhail tao and a
friend of mine joseph gallagher
grandmaster from england was recalling
the story where he he played him in a
simultaneous when he was like 12. he saw
him 20 years later and there's 30 people
playing 30 plus people he saw him in a
lift like 20 years later and he's like i
have to have to sort of say something he
says oh hello mikael i played you in a
simultaneous in england and uh you're
thinking that you would have no idea at
all and michael goes all right oh yeah
just got a bit more information he said
it was this variation and
mikael said oh yes you should have
played um blah blah blah like bishop
takes f6 on move 22 and then you would
have been winning and it's like
how on earth could you recall from 30
games one move variation from 20 years
ago and when you're i mean it's i mean
can you remember any simultaneous games
you play i i certainly do the ones who
gave me some trouble yes i that i
remember them right yeah i mean i it
just goes in one ear out the other for
me this simultaneous is generally but
it's it's incredible it's an incredible
yes stories you hear about these super
feats of the mind really uh to do the
chess and yeah magnus certainly has it i
mean recording that song
is is quite incredible
i mean i think the trick is just keeping
the mind active i mean magnus he
constantly does quizzes he's constantly
trying to read research new things
keeping his mind active as possible so i
don't think he's specifically trying to
train his memory or just his memory i
think it's just kind of
obviously he has that kind of natural
sponge-like uh brain but
yeah he's definitely pushing himself all
the time and meanwhile if we get back to
the current position it has changed
slightly but not too much right now
black has regained the pawn that he
temporarily sacrificed and white's queen
has just come out black's pieces are
nice and active but black's pawn
structure is slightly compromised so
just to jump in to show what is likely
to be a factor over the next 10 15 moves
it's all about this isolated pawn and
we've talked about this a lot actually
throughout the uh the event throughout
the chesapeal masters this isolated pawn
comes from a whole variety of openings
it comes from the queen's gambit it
comes from the karakan comes from from
the french defense and
here they will be using pattern
recognition to try and figure out how to
compensate for this weakness in his
position here magnus this is a weakness
but also white's queen at least for now
attacking this pawn
so um you can defend that in a couple of
ways for example you can bring your
knight to the square it looks a bit
weird but at least you defend the center
you block the white queen
another alternative would be to try and
uh maybe just bring the black queen out
to challenge the white queen
lots of options here at some point
magnus will be looking for an
opportunity to maybe push this pawn to
trade it off to trade off his weakness
but for now white is covering that
square with his knight and with his pawn
could he go active here david i mean
could it could he uh when you've got the
isolated pawn you really don't want to
generally exchange queens and go passive
but
could he throw a knight into the center
of the board as i mean i don't know if
you can just
take that pawn in the middle but i mean
you'd like to do something active if you
can i feel um i mean it's a common idea
right yeah having an isolated point the
benefits are that you control a lot of
squares this one for example this one
you have an open line for your rook
later on if you need it and simon as you
mentioned this is definitely on magnus's
radar yeah you can play this move it
will be very good yeah i mean even if
queen takes pawn you can you've got a
lot of play here i mean even if you
i don't know play something like knight
f6 but maybe there's something stronger
than that move into position it seems
you're you're at least active here we
could see a scenario like this you're
right simon that black actually gives up
his isolated pawn in the center just to
create active pieces the rook now
fantastic the night now fantastic and uh
yeah definitely some compensation here
and uh all these things are going
through magnus's mind does he sacrifice
his pawn does he passively defend it
i'm not sure whether he's disconnected
magnus we don't see his camera right now
but he's five minutes down on the clock
now it is a critical moment he needs to
deal with this pawn uh the threat
against both of these pawns actually a
dual threat here from ding but he needs
to move he needs to come up with
something
yeah definitely and uh well interesting
move there that you suggested simon and
i just wanted to talk about our quiz of
the day because we're asking what is
your best tip to improve chess openings
and a lot of people giving great advice
i have to say i do like nikolai's
british sense of humor when he says that
my way of improving openings is being
brutally beaten by much better players
that's how i fixed my queen's gambit
accepted and picked up the infamous
budapest garbage
sometimes you've got to know when to
quit and choose something else
but you know i liked it and ryan baker
gives the advice that they recommend
finding an opening that sets up a
position that suits you as a player we
had that advice as well from yesterday's
uh guest
and of course chesapore i mean
absolutely chesterboard's a fantastic uh
resource to use i use it quite often and
i find it does help with my memory i can
actually
just
i just remember things specific
repetition yeah because of the practice
and i try to kind of make sure that i'm
like 80 percent
i'm sorry not 80 errors that was not the
word i wanted i wanted 80 success rate
when i practice because it means that my
mind is still learning so that would be
also my my tip
great great advice from everyone and if
you two want to enter our quiz of the
day
then you can tweet us using the hashtag
chesschamps and there's an amazing prize
up for grabs it's a semi-slav lifetime
repertoire by sam shanklin and this air
things wave device hey yeah yeah big
prize today it is you get two for
answering only one question
so do twitter's hashtag chesschamps and
sam shanklin's course it has a value of
210 dollars so it is a great price
in addition to the air things device and
we did see magnus's air quality stats a
little earlier remember he is playing
from denmark this time and it was
looking
good for him
looks like denmark is good for magnus
carlson suddenly temperature is okay
looks like it's good it looks like it's
good i don't think the internet
connection in denmark however is very
good because we've lost magnus's webcam
again again and also look at the clock
times he spent more than half his time
on this one move oh wait is he offline
that makes me think he might be
disconnected because yes it's a critical
position yes it's kind of a middle game
position where you have to start
planning calculating but it's not like
magnus to spend this much time on one
move this early in the game magnus
normally trusts his instinct or he finds
a move that's good enough
to spend six minutes in this position
something must be he's moved so um and
he didn't get any time back did he get
any time back so wow he really did
invest six minutes in this one move
and he just steps back with the black
bishop um interesting idea here he's
actually offering a sacrifice in two
different ways
and the question is can ding win a pawn
here can ding just get greedy is greed
good in this position and
magnus he probably then spent the last
six minutes working out whether white
for example can take this pawn with his
queen if this happens that at the very
then at the very least black's rook can
activate blackstrap can kick the queen
away and when the white queen continues
munching on pawns the black rook can
jump into the position
and uh maybe this active rook is
good enough it's a decent comp uh
compensation for the sacrificed pawn
white queen meanwhile offside in siberia
somewhere
not doing too much so this is one option
for white it's still complicated but uh
if we backtrack after magnus's move
we're treating the bishop other than
taking this white pawn other than white
taking this pawn sorry he can grab in
the center and this is the most critical
because this is a key pawn
if black can't get compensation he's
just pawn down for nothing i think the
idea might be
hmm i'm trying to figure it out here
simon but to trade and then move the
black knight yeah or knight c5 maybe
immediately i could could also be okay
an option i feel here um
yeah i was also wondering whether the
black knight could actually jump in
immediately to e4 square okay yeah so
this is one idea this is another idea
eyeing up this bishop very complicated
isn't it already very complicated all of
the knights jumping into the center of
the board i think this is a great
decision in general because i i felt
that if he hadn't played something like
this david that his position might just
be worse you know he has to sort of
defend passively and i think a good bit
of advice for everyone out there you
know if your position is going downhill
it's getting worse and worse which it
seemed like magnus's position okay it
might not be massive but it was you can
try to do something a little bit uh
drastic as in you can try to uh you know
sacrifice a pawn just to complicate the
position gives you some chances rather
than sit and defend passively so i i in
in general i like it but that's without
analyzing it at all of course and i just
want to show something a bit funny here
simon so for example the black knight is
kind of indirectly attacking this bishop
say white defends it and uh black's
knight jumps into the center of the
board
we could see a situation with uh ah yeah
look at these oh let's please let's have
that that would be
can we just can they just have a draw
then it seems like appropriate to
oh uh you can't do that but you don't
want to ruin that position either hang
on can they get the bishops around them
as well you know anyway uh yeah just
looking for patterns but in the current
position if ding for example does play
this move knight takes pawn then uh you
guys are right um ivanka thinking okay
maybe the black knight can jump in here
simon mentioning the black knight can
jump in here uh attacking the white
queen and he has played this so he has
had to calculate all of these options um
also in the current position i was
looking at ideas like this one setting
up a really sneaky threat and the white
queen now undefended if white is
careless for example just improves the
rook then suddenly this undefended queen
drops off the board lpdo lose pieces
drop off and bishop takes pawn is a
check getting rid of the bishop gaining
time against the white king and when the
bishop gets captured then it's a
discovered attack against the white
queen and black's queen pounces so lots
and lots of options here for magnus
carlsen in the current position
which night is he going to move i think
he's going to move one of these nights
and uh for your plan david goes for this
one i'm not sure what's going on
he's gone this way wow
interesting so the idea is that this
knight is offering itself up for bait uh
but if the night is captured then this
actually
was a bit of a pin and black's bishop
can jump in and bart jumps up for
dangler i mean we were surprised by this
move just
i'm not sure what the exact threat is as
well
in the current position as magnus maybe
wants to lift his rook up the board and
uh start hitting the white queen
i don't really see the threat and if
there's no threat then maybe one of the
white rooks can come to the center of
the board or the white bishop for
example can step forward hitting this
black knight i say there's no threat
because if there's a trade the important
thing is that now the white bishop
actually covers the white queen so that
the tactic i showed a moment ago of
black bishop taking this pawn doesn't
really work for example here um now
black's queen can take the white queen
but it's just recaptured by the white
bishop and white actually wins a piece
so what's the idea i don't really
understand it feels like magnus has
spent a lot of time
maybe maybe you can try that rook lift
after your move david so bishop c3
magnus has to play something aggressive
and then now i guess well let's see what
happens if you grab another pawn is
there something on h2 here
this is where this is why he might have
invested
a lot of time
the idea is to drive the white queen as
far away as possible from her king and
then after a trade maybe uh possibly
here jumping in sacrificing everything
to break through to the white king and
uh this will end in checkmate that's
really nice actually i think this is
what magnus has in his mind um the white
king now is caught
no way to stop the black queen coming
down
and uh yeah checkmate
so yeah okay it is scary actually this
rook move uh maybe this is magnus's
hidden
idea so would you say a win for either
player is the most likely result right
now yeah yes yeah definitely i mean
white's material up but magnus is
attacking so you know either white wins
with the extra material or or magnus
attack comes through so very uh exciting
moment on the board at the moment
definitely
he is definitely up on the clock but
thinking for two minutes now game two
has also started between pragnanda and
anish geary apparently it's a much more
exciting game than the first one we will
go to that one when
magnus and ding finishes their game too
yeah and uh for ding it's all about
survival right now i think if he can
navigate the next five to ten moves
successfully if he can just survive
cling on to his extra pawn
he's gonna win this game um i just don't
see magnus fighting back but it is about
those tactics those attacks those tricks
those sacrifices breaking through to the
white king and that's why we see ding
with his head in his hands it's just
super complicated right now it's a very
good time to have a think yeah
and this is again what strong players do
very regularly they get to a position
which is critical this position could be
the turning point the whole game we just
saw that if white plays it badly he can
get checkmated but if he finds the right
way through the calculations he could be
a pawn up and again i think it's a great
learning tip you can play generally in
chess even in a very long time limit a
lot of moves very quickly well most of
us can david and
sorry
but you you can generally but then when
there's a critical moment you you can
spend you have to spend a lot of time on
these critical moments to work and work
things out but i know you do it david to
try and work out your plan and to just
just to get yourself comfortable so i
was reading a book about this exact same
thing that you know top players the
super ground masters actually you know
they first of all orient themselves with
like the actual position and then the
choices and then once they've kind of
decided they really go deep into it and
they calculate
which is something that uh
lower rated players tend to actually
intuitively try to feel their way around
the play around the moves right just
calculation calculation yeah i mean for
the top players um they always joke and
i think it's actually true that their
minds are actually a bit of a muddle at
first
so for example ding magnus they're so
good that you show them a position
immediately they'll see three four moves
ahead in one variation or maybe another
variation but only then do they have to
stop take a step back make sure that
they haven't missed anything on the
journey so often here for example that
line we showed that ended in checkmate
king will see that instantly but then
he'll take a step back he'll spend four
or five minutes trying to work out oh
where can i improve on that line is
every move
forced for me is every move force for my
opponent where are the options
and that's why they spend four or five
minutes you always see them thinking
longest as well in positions where they
have to plan and where they have
four or five moves which look roughly
the same value
so okay eventually he moves his rook
across
very logical but now the big question is
can black's rook lift up the board
that's what we showed a moment ago this
rook move actually maybe it's a bit
clever because the white king does have
an escape route towards the center if it
needs
so the big question for magnus how can
he justify his pawn sacrifice
um we could have a look maybe
see if the same line as before actually
works there i mean uh so um yeah let's
let's go for it so the rook does the
same thing i guess white grabs that pawn
and then black's kind of in an all-in
situation here two pawns down yeah so he
has to take on f3 opening up the bishop
and here white's got to take with the
bishop keeping his king closed now does
bishop takes h2 work and they both must
have looked at this quite deeply i mean
uh
i i i
i guess you can get away of it here just
by coming to the center right the
difference is now the white king in this
position it looks like this is checkmate
and it is inevitable this queen coming
down but um yeah ding he's evacuated
with his rook move he's evacuated this
key square and now the white king can
just run he can just make its journey
into the center of the board and it
doesn't look entirely safe there but
white is actually a piece and a pawn up
you have queen c4 though and these oh no
queen takes her free yeah i know but
then still queen c4 and then the king
comes back okay so
just just to show you what simon means
there's a queen check here so for
example if the king walks into the wrong
direction there is a checkmate
but i think unfortunately the king walks
back
this way and after the queen swings
across again to try and checkmate now
white can safely
for example just push a pawn and the
white queen actually keeps some key
squares defended but you can pull this
check and you run again
but you're right you think this is the
difference with these players that they
see these kind of things immediately you
know um straight away they better
calculate that this is this is safe um
but if if that means what's he done okay
he's come in then two to c2 which is
also very logical it's logical but now
this rook it does
i mean it feels like there's a
disconnect between this rook and the
rest of his army this rook is just going
pawn hunting everything else is defended
but
somehow it's a bit loose this knight is
a bit loose this bishop is a bit loose
this bishop um it's all on an open line
is
is there any like immediate try um i'm
thinking of bishop moving to the c3
square
so white's bishop can clear out the way
um now trying to create a pin i guess
black can for example take this white
bishop and then bishop takes knight is
the idea and then i guess you have to
retreat yeah i mean this looks very good
for white to be honest
there's a pin along this line so black's
bishop cannot take the white bishop
because now after queen takes queen
remember as well this is a background
checkmate black's king lacks escape
squares
um yeah suddenly i mean i don't know if
magnus calculated this right or it feels
like there's something wrong with
magnus's place somehow
i mean all the bishop moves are possible
actually ivanka you've mentioned bishop
c3 you can go to b4 or even a5
you know all of these ones i know all of
these actually to me look quite scary to
magnus because uh you're forcing things
on the default and you're a porn up and
i think it's actually a
dingler and who's got the initiative
this this could be starting to be really
scary i mean you know does this win him
some material wow which i mean this is
this is
this is a scary move bishop b4 the more
i look at that i mean i mean they're all
scary what'd you do you know they're all
very this one attacks the black queen
and it
unleashes the white rook so now you're
attacking this bishop with your queen
and simon mentioned this uh this other
bishop jump is more flashy and maybe
even more effective because you're
attacking this bishop and remember if
this black bishop moves then
black walks into this uh pin type of
idea queen takes queen and
once again this check it's not deadly
this time because the black bishop can
come and block but white has won a rook
for bishop in the process
so uh yeah all this moves looking good i
just cheated
you have to go flashy this is this is a
good move and bishop a5 doesn't work it
wins on the spot oh really wow wow
really this wins on the spot for ding
okay oh what about bishop a5 does that
win as well i mean just like that that's
not mentioned it's not let's bring up
the suggestions uh what moves does the
computer want to play we're thinking
moving this bishop but three big choices
and okay uh this computer at least
thinks that the bishop moved to this
square is good um it thinks that white
can simply take this black knight in the
center of the board as well he thinks
that white is doing well if you push a
pawn but as ivanka mentioned maybe with
a bit more time the computer will
realize that this move for white is
winning so we're saying the computers
can't really work this out either way
having complicated having different we
haven't done views and computers here
yeah i mean it depends on like how
quickly the engine processes things and
sees things but yeah it's all about this
pin yeah
and and the key point is actually after
knight takes nights that's the only
recommendation that you don't capture
with a bishop you're captured oh wow oh
this is difficult oh yeah it's unnatural
to take with the pawn and open up your
own king that's incredible if he finds
this i mean
okay any any we know he's a genius sting
but yeah
level this is different gravy as we say
in england sometimes why would that be
better though uh taking with the porn
now that you i've no idea either
i think the idea is actually it's
findable because after the white bishop
takes suddenly the black bishop can give
itself up go on a suicide mission give a
check then after white takes back now
the black queen jumps in and now because
you've opened up this line if your
bishop was still back here this wouldn't
work for black but because you've opened
up this line the rook and the queen
combine on this square so black jumps in
with a check the white king moves the
black queen gives back with the check
and look at this it's a miracle but
black saves by repeating the moves
black's queen just goes back and forth
and it's a draw it's a check white
cannot escape from
and it is possible for dink to calculate
that if that is on the board i think
ding would see that this is a draw and
then by process of elimination you
backtrack then you trace your steps back
and you realize that in this position so
he's gone for the fourth bishop move i
can't believe it so we looked at the
other three moves and he's gone for
number four
it's your favorite move though david my
favorite move
it makes sense we just showed this
variation where the black queen ends up
on this square
oh it takes only a few moves but now
he's protected this square with his
bishop yeah maybe that's really cunning
from ding i mean it's so unnatural
normally you look forward with the
bishop you look this way this way this
way you're attacking pieces no matter
where you go he's not attacking anything
at all he's just taking a step back
he has however opened up this line
remember and uh yeah still very very
complicated
and uh maybe magnus can fight back
ticking down on the clock as well i
think we're going to see a blunder from
one of the two players
because it's that type of position it's
impossible to play perfectly it's so
complicated typical that magnus has
internet connection problems with his
webcam in this game
i wish i could see his uh reactions um
okay so black's rook snacked on one of
the white bishops and now white has
recaptured uh one of the black knights
so his level material again white just
has one extra pawn and this bishop's
under fire oh this bishop's under fire
hang on i saw a trick okay so basically
the light square bishop can actually
retreat itself
to this particular square to attack the
queen yeah and you know you could go
queen takes bishop and you go well why
are you giving me a piece and i go well
the joke's on you because i'm going to
play rick takes bishop and distract your
work away from the defense deflection
tactic uh as we call it this is a check
uh white's rook needs to move away and
capture this black rook but then the
white rook loses control of its own
queen
and black emerges with an extra queen so
yep that would be a nice tactic from
magnus dropping the bishop back i guess
here my uh ding would spot the idea and
just retreat to a safe square i'm not
sure exactly where though uh maybe just
back one square keeping an eye on the
knight
under two minutes on the clock
will he lose the first game in the
semi-final can dingle around win this
yeah i mean ding
how did he play that bishop move how did
he even find it i mean it's such a
clever idea dropping white's bishop back
but as we just showed in ivanka's line
there that white bishop is actually a
target as well so even bishop takes
knight here is incredibly complex and it
looks like it can't be played because i
know it can't be played just queen takes
queen right
yeah
i'm just yeah
sorry again so bishop takes knight
bishop takes knight okay it's also
possible because you've got some i mean
can you play the ridiculous queen takes
rook takes e3
i mean just uh let's show this uh
off short variation so we have to show
this it's on the board but here black
would be able to win the game actually
by giving a check and then picking off
the black queen two bishops will beat
one rook so if we backtrack um this was
played so instead of queen takes queen
which looks winning but doesn't actually
work he took this bishop and now magnus
as you mentioned that simon took this
pawn so he's unleashing an attack
against this rook and against this queen
and after queen takes rook it's level
material now but ding is going to be in
charge after this bishop joins the
action that's why bishop is going to
start threatening the black king
it's called calm down a little bit now
you know they're not so sure
it's a little bit less tactical we can
just take a breather for a second you
know it's like um but it does look like
white's in control here right i mean
just with the bishop is so strong yeah
and the queen side pawn is on pre as
well over so and as david is
highlighting you know just uh have a
look at the dark square bishop and its
targets as well and i always say you
know whoever
has the initiative whoever has the
attack going on opposite color bishops
middle games
has the advantage it's very very
difficult for black to even think about
defending on the dark square color
complex i agree it does look nice for
white still white must have an advantage
but is it going to be enough here yeah
so opposite color bishops if the queens
and rooks get traded it's just going to
be a draw but temporarily white has the
attack um on this square in front of the
black king but also um this pawn that
simon mentioned and uh actually ding
gets greedy he doesn't even go for the
black king in the uh current position he
just went and grabbed this pawn
maybe greed is good but now magnus is
able to centralize and blacks are pawn
down again it won't matter if the queens
and rooks come off opposite colour
bishops would just be a draw black will
blockade on the light squares but can
black survive to that point still
white's bishop is much better than
black's bishop it's definitely ding who
has the winning chances magnus cannot
really win this game unless there's a
big big blunder and look at ding's last
move after the black brook moved across
he just pushes upon creating some space
for his king you need to have some luft
um some air just to avoid any checkmates
and black does the same breathing space
so now the game will slow down it was a
bit crazy but uh at least in terms of
the position it will slow down the
clocks are ticking
and do you think ding is uh fighting to
uh to win this game now he wants to
spend some time now to find a winning
plan yes uh i think this is going to be
as good an opportunity as ding will get
in any game
against magnus it's it still won't be
easy because opposite color bishops and
oh trading queens i'm not sure i like
that one but it's allowed a check as
well he's obviously not scared of the
rook coming in the same same tactic
which you pointed out you've anchored a
couple of times
like that move at all and the reason i
don't like it is actually because of the
check that you highlighted yeah and then
i think the rook can
park itself on the f1 square i mean then
maybe there might be even a trade okay
so just to show this black can okay we
do see a trade
and black gives a check uh if he wants
and the white king moving ivanka you
think the black rook will just move
across one square yeah no maybe not
actually i've changed my mind just to
show your point again uh if the king
moves for example now you can force a
trade of rooks and uh after rook takes
rook bishop takes this is gonna be a
draw most likely because yes white is
one point up but black can blockade all
these pawns on the light squares
opposite colour bishops you cannot break
through on the white squares um instead
magnus brings his bishop away he just
wants to reroute his bishop back to this
square it's going to be a long hard
difficult defense here for magnus um if
magnus was white i would say this is
going to be a win now with one extra
pawn but
he's such a good defender magnus ding
meanwhile trying to push push his
majority it's two versus one on this
side of the board
still not easy no still not easy i mean
ding's been in charge of the match
hasn't he so far i mean the first game
he he was uh he did very well magnus
missed his chances and in this game he's
uh the only one with winning chance to
say if he can get a pass pawn on that
side of the board so david you're saying
draw
uh
i mean
again it's the magnus factor if yeah if
it was anyone other than magnus's black
i would say white's going to win yeah or
if magnus was white i would say white
would win but because it's magnus i'll
say right okay i'll go win okay i'll go
win you vancouver
i'm gonna go
draw because it's magnus magnus always
draws these things okay but the bar is
creeping up again for dingley run with
these last few moves yeah it feels like
it should he should have some way to
keep the white pawns safe if the white
pawns can push forward to dark squares
where they can be defended by white's
bishop uh the left the pawns on the
queen side on the left side then i think
white has great winning chances but at
the moment the white pawns are stuck on
the light squares so they are targets
for the black rook and the black bishop
so it's just about whether white can
safely push his pawns somehow ding's
trying to work that out under one minute
now
um
yeah i mean if michael adams the english
number one was on the white side here he
would win as well he wins every single
opposite color bishop game with rooks
when it's white star square bishop
against the black light squared bishop
okay
but is this a you know clock's ticking
dang is down to 40 seconds on the clock
is it a position where you can make
blunders
not
really i think if you make a blunder you
just lose a pawn back and then it will
be a draw so i think ding is playing for
two results a win or a draw okay i think
a win for magnus is out of the uh it's
just not on the cards right now and
there we go he pushes one of his pawns
forward
black forces some weaknesses though
black is going for the white king and
the pawns around it
magnus playing very fast it's committal
black is trying to win a pawn back but
he's completely ignored white's pawns
and there they go the pawns are marching
it's pretty sharp still i mean did this
a pawn it's only it's only a couple of
squares from queening isn't it if you
can just uh bring the bishop back and
just shove the a pawn up the border or
something similar um
just try and queen it i mean the black
rook is out of play at the moment so he
has brought the bishop back okay anytime
and i don't know if you need to push it
now but it looks scary if you do
yeah i definitely think magnus has been
okay i really like this move from ding
magnus is trying to hustle here on the
clock he's trying to play as quickly as
possible as tricky as possible now i
think the white king is going towards
the black bishop
um black has won the pawn back so it's
level material but it's all about that
two versus one majority on the left side
i don't see really how ding is going to
stop them long term that being said
the white king not entirely safe at the
moment yeah i'm not a big fan of how
things have developed actually
just now because i i mean
suddenly magnus has done his thing you
know where he puts his pieces on the
best squares and white's pawns on the
left side are just paralyzed
it looks like a good diagonal where
black's got that bishop because you
can't push the a pawn because the the
black bishop is tying down
the queen side a little bit here
so um i i i think i i would change my
idea to it being a draw now if i'm
allowed to
be stuck with your predictions
okay
and i i know this i notice royal rule
you never bet against magnus in an
ending it doesn't matter what side it's
on what color he is what position you
always go with magnus every single time
whenever i bet against him i always lose
i mean every single time so it's just
you know you might be a pawn down two
pawns down yeah peter might say plus two
three for the opponent he'll draw yeah
and likewise if the computer says 0.0
he'll win
yeah that's just magnus carlsen in a
nutshell okay the white rook going
active the white rook protects the pawn
next to it trying to free up the white a
pawn from uh to push so simon uh
indicating that the black bishop was
holding up those white pawns
it's still it's still definitely magnus
on the defensive is
the kind of two versus one majority now
black has one on the king side but the
white king will hold up any black pawn
advances it's just about the other flank
if white can somehow win the black
bishop for his pawns on the left side
then he has great winning chances
okay magnus just waits
and is he going to offer a trade of
rooks potentially here
yeah
if the rooks come off the board remember
black will blockade on the light squares
white can't break through on that color
complex
then they will immediately sort of agree
a draw somehow very quick uh quick path
towards a draw so can ding keep the
rooks on the board that is the question
for example white's rook can go up to
the top of the board to give a check
but no
trades off
absolutely i thought that check would be
happening and maybe
i think you needed to unfortunately the
players go it is a draw it is a draw
game two but dingley ran with the white
pieces wow he was pushing for a win in
this one